pay for two years yeah and I have been
doing comedy for more than 20 and we
were co-headlining so I would headline
one night he would headline the other
night and mean to be able to go on after
a guy who's been doing comedy 24 years
or whatever the [ __ ] was yeah and go
on after him and do 40 minutes
whenever we'll do it yeah and just the
balls - yeah yeah yeah yeah and he was
just go on out there like you own the
place but passed away right yeah jeez
passed away yeah bout a little over a
year ago Wow I think all the people that
we work with in that they're not here
anymore a lot of them gone my good god
something ones it suck [ __ ] hey I worked
you know you always make it a point and
babay post a little material
one of the biggest things that all of us
all each operator I never met him he was
this big big fat redneck guy and we're
working down south someplace maybe
Florida and we're in the green room and
he watches The Tonight Show and it's on
and we're doing the Late Show and Kasich
comes up does his monologue and after
smiley Samuel aren't you pretty he went
out and did gosh no one will ever know
there was no VC eyes back then there was
no tapes there was nothing I got and he
stole one of my judgment you so much
okay yeah but I do it better I got no
you don't to it man it's oh yeah but I
do it better yeah yeah that's what he's
young kids yeah man but I do it better
well you know back in the day in the
catskills times they all stole mmm like
there was there was no honor amongst
thieves back then and everyone just had
jokes there were just joked jokes like
you almost had like a tool box like oh I
needed 3/8 mmm and then as television
came along and then people started
getting in trouble for stealing you know
robbed and got in trouble and a few
other guys got in trouble and then it
sort of died off until like I mean when
YouTube came along then it kind of
killed it there's a still a few thieves
that are still running around to this
day and some of them are famous but most
of the audience knows now and if you
look look at someone who's a thief
then you look at their Instagram
comments like holy [ __ ] people go after
them yeah people know now they know it's
the darkest thing you can do when a guy
works or a girl works forever on a bit
and then you just come along at the
finished product and snatch it and
switch a couple words and pretend
pretend you came up with it on your own
well when I started I was working as a
janitor in City Hall of Cambridge and I
took the other janitors out for BS when
we went to the Spring Fair station alone
we saw Sweeney and we saw Sweeney and
Bill Campbell and M going oh my god
Sweeney was just it was wow this guy
ever see anything like it I had a couple
of guys it's a couple of comics when I
make the Janice it get funnier than
these guys you should so I talked to
George MacDonald about it at school the
next day of use yeah man you should be a
comedian I go what sad because that's
what you saw last night
his house and we listen to Woody Allen
album and I don't even know woody I know
buddy Allen from smoke I'd know he was a
comedian and he did that joke about
hitting the Moose up in Maine so I went
on and I've been on stage before they
went on at the but the thing always
spring frustrates alone and I did this
and it was unbelievable change all my
every stunt with supplies like a stair
the relation and afterwards this little
old guy comes in the back mr. clock
you're very funny but you shouldn't use
Woody Allen material you what do you
[ __ ] you manage and that was it that was
it and I sucked for months I said but it
was all mine you know it was crazy yeah
there's a lot of guys in the beginning
that's Greg Fitzsimmons and I used to
steal from each other we have a deal
though like a fuse because we both only
have like 15 minutes and we had to do a
half so I would steal 15 is he'd still
15 of mine and we were best friends
oh yeah so we go to do that [ __ ]
material killed and [ __ ] pocket took
anyone I said Kenny that was [ __ ]
pretty us that sure is you [ __ ]
morning defense Rachel cuz I don't know
what I was doing I can't remember as I
just see the best guys oh there's no
ideas you got to be heightened for Joey
upstage with a notebook yeah you got to
go
say that again the [ __ ] did I say